[Musique]
150 degrés
nous avons perdu quelques affaires parce que ce que
nous faisions ici au marché aux poissons
était le transbordement donc il y aurait du poisson d'
Islande qui descendrait nous
le retirons du conteneur nous le ferions  triez-le de la façon dont il
le met dans des kits, puis exportez-le dans
un puits à ballons qui s'arrête, alors ce que les
Islandais ont fait pour éviter toutes les
complications liées aux retards, les
formalités administratives, le dédouanement et tout
ça, ils ont commencé à aller
directement pour que le poisson puisse  passer de l'Islande
directement en France et cela contournerait les
étrangers du Royaume-Uni.
[Musique] [Musique
]
[Musique]
n'est jamais arrivé parce que je veux juste
revenir à une époque où je copiais et
collais les emails de la semaine précédente pour
les envoyer à des fournisseurs européens  ils
répondaient simplement, ils le feraient et deux jours
plus tard, le poisson est arrivé, ces jours-là étaient
faciles et c'est pourquoi, en tant qu'homme d'affaires
dans l'industrie de la pêche, j'ai voté pour rester
exactement comme avant. Nous avons tous voté d'
un point de vue personnel, mais mon
point de vue personnel  d'un point de vue, les affaires étaient géniales, pourquoi
les changer
[Musique]
merci les
étrangers
[Musique]
Je veux dire, ce qui se passe à Grimsby, c'est
que nous nous éloignons du
secteur traditionnel des fruits de mer, nous avons maintenant
l'éolien offshore, il y a une grande partie du  l'
économie locale, donc le port de Grimsby
est maintenant le plus grand port au monde pour les
opérations et la maintenance de l'énergie éolienne offshore.
Nous sommes à quelques kilomètres de là, nous avons le
port d'Immingham qui est le plus grand
port en volume du Royaume-Uni.  le commerce
en général, donc il
se passe énormément de choses dans l'économie locale et la
transformation du poisson n'en est qu'une partie,
oh